some 160 men who died of arsenic
poisoning lie buried in the cemeteries
of Eastern hungry most were killed by
their wives in the years following World
War one women known as angel makers got
the arsenic from pesticides usually from
flypaper the murders drew international
attention two women were executed and
numerous others sentenced to life in
prison today arsenic is once again
making headlines in the same region for
instance in the town of ellic Nicolette
Perdue she lives here but until recently
she had no idea that her drinking water
contains levels of arsenic which for
exceed those considered safe each leader
contains 15 micrograms of the poison let
me go sour that connect to the Thermomix
inning we didn't know there was a snake
in the water I think most people still
aren't aware of it and to date nothing
has been done about it we simply haven't
been informed but thanks to the European
Union that might be about to change at
the beginning of this year it threatened
hungry with sanctions after issuing
warnings about the poor water quality in
this region for over a decade now with
the help of the National Army filtration
systems are quickly being assembled in
this factory building there to provide
the worst affected villages with cleaner
water we have the situation completely
under control the government has
contracted us to produce these systems
they put 19 million euros at our
disposal by the middle of the year we'll
be setting up 200 such containers in the
affected villages this year a Bazin
initiator in a long run the communities
could eliminate the need for filtration
systems by digging deeper wells but many
lack the money back in ellic the whole
town hopes that some
will change soon the mayor is waiting
for the promised filtration system it's
to be set up here in the courtyard of
the local psychiatric hospital residents
and the hospital's cafeteria could then
finally have access to clean water until
a long-term solution is found little man
some say they'll collide you could bear
his fear were near the Romanian border
the water over there is clean
together with our Romanian neighbors
we've developed a potable water project
over the last five years it just needs
to be signed off by the two governments
but for more than a year now nothing's
happening but at the ministry
responsible for environment and water
they see things differently what Kate
Foster coal mine the previous two
socialist governments didn't find a
solution and left the local government
in the lurch and the pressure being
exerted by the EU to change the
situation right away costs us extra
money as far as the Hungarian Romanian
project is concerned we're open to it
but the Romanian side has yet to sign
the necessary permits pediatrician
Laszlo Szabo can't believe that the
cleanups keep being delayed across the
entire region
he says the effects of arsenic and
drinking water are significant
that ENFP Navarro Bhushan ugaki small
children and pregnant women are most
affected arsenic and lead to
miscarriages it can cause skin cancer -
statistically speaking we can't
ascertain just how widespread these
illnesses are in the affected regions
they're very poor areas in which there
could be many reasons for such illnesses
but an austro-german company shows just
how simple a quick fix could be it's
donated these water filters to local
daycare centers you guys that point out
your on both we've worked together with
the Hungarian Red Cross which is how the
donation came to be made it's very
simple they've done in two minutes you
have clean water it's not wash to be
that it's just a drop in the bucket but
one that they'd be happy for in ellic
here there's no filtration system at all
residents are exposed to the dangerous
arsenic everywhere 12 years after the
Hungarian government promised the EU it
would solve the problem Nicolette /
Ritchie can't understand why nothing's
being done to them madam - I think they
need I don't know why drinking water was
only becoming an issue now the problems
been around for years but no one did
anything about it the public authorities
should have done something about it long
ago he burned alone cleaning up the
arsenic problem is expected to cost
around a billion euros Hungary must pay
just a third of that with the EU footing
the rest of the bill the government in
Budapest says the cleanup could take two
years until then every drop of arsenic
in the water is a reminder of the angel
makers and their sinister legacy
you